[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais à donner à l'état les attendait
bizarre c'est une édition très spéciale
qui démarre aujourd'hui il si tu auras
côté merci scellé dans le cameraman qui
derrière merci à tous d'être avec nous
dans touche pas à mon poste vous
explique un petit peu le dossier c'est
que je rencontre michael jackson au
sortant de l'ascenseur je dis bien
démarrer l'émission avec tout vous
n'avez pas du tout préparés et on s'est
retrouvé sur une chorégraphie de
thriller
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci d'avoir été là c'est qu'on va nous
attendre à ce que j'espère gaspard voilà
qui étaient avec nous michael forever
and haas auquel elle tenait jeudi mais
je les croise hélas pas nous faire une
petite démo rapide mais vraiment sûr du
boisé basile à désirer la musique alors
voyez la musique
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]